let's look at chapter two
on linear functions so we'll start by
talking about linear and affine
functions
i find as we'll see is a slight
extension of linear functions which is
also very useful comes up in a lot of
applications
okay so let's start with some notation
so looks complicated but this is
standard mathematical notation
this thing that says f colon and then
this bold r
with a superscript and r what that says
is that f
is a function and f takes as argument or
an input
or what it what it takes in is an n
vector
so that's what this r and means and then
what it does is it gives you back a real
number that's what this r
over here means so that's a some people
would call it a scalar valued function
just a function lots of ways to think
about functions ranging from informal to
formal
informally you can think of it as
something like a process that takes
n numbers in something happens and it
gives you a number back
you could think of it as a subroutine in
a computer program or you could think of
it as simply
one one real number that's the output
which depends on n real numbers and you
can think of those as the input
and so we would write things like this f
of u
here u is a
vector so it's a vector it's a list of n
numbers
and then f of u this whole thing here is
a number
okay so that's the uh that's that's the
notation
okay now a function from r n to r uh
that's how you pronounce this
satisfies what's called the
superposition property if the following
holds and
these equations are things you have to
look at sort of you have to look at them
very carefully very quietly make sure
you understand everything in them
because there's a lot of overloading
going on so they look completely
reasonable it says a juxtaposition of
symbols you
read it and you're like sure why not but
you really have to kind of be very
present and aware
uh thinking about what all the parts
mean so let's take a look at it
superposition property says you start
with a vector x and a vector y
and you start with two scalars alpha and
beta and then you form a linear
combination that's alpha x plus beta y
then it says after you form a linear
combination
evaluate apply f okay and so you get f
of alpha x plus beta y
and this whole left hand side is a
number three minus two point six
i don't know okay now let's look at the
right hand side the right hand side
says we're actually going to do this in
the reverse order we're gonna first
apply the function to
x and we're also going to apply the
function to y now those two things are
numbers right because f takes this
argument a vector
x in this case over here and then it
returns a number so f of x is a number
so is f of y and so over here alpha
alpha next to f of x which is a number
is just ordinary multiplication of two
numbers that's ordinary addition of two
numbers and the whole thing on the right
is a number and that's good because the
left hand side is a number two
what superposition says is that actually
you get the same thing
if you form the linear combination
basically before applying the function
or after and and the way you might say
that in fact the way a mathematician
would say it is they'd say that
that the function f commutes with linear
combinations in other words you can
either do it before
or after the order doesn't matter so
that's a very special
function i mean a very special property
and actually very few functions actually
satisf you know
satisfy this exactly but we'll see that
a lot of a lot of functions that occur
in the wild
uh actually satisfy this either very
closely or
uh or quite well approximately
[Music]
and we'll also see that a lot of uh
constructed functions
functions that will make up actually do
satisfy linearity
okay so uh if a function satisfies
a superposition the superposition
property which says that basically it
commutes with forming linear
combinations
then you call the function linear and
and that's that's very standard in
in mathematics uh that's in fact it's a
concept that goes throughout all of
mathematics
applied mathematics all of engineering
economic i mean just
tons and tons of fields statistics a lot
of stuff based on
on this idea okay so now right now this
is all very abstract but
hopefully soon this will be less
abstract and therefore probably more
interesting
okay so here's an example of a function
that's linear
and it is the inner product function so
let's see what we let's be very careful
about this
so we'll start with an n vector a just a
vector
um but you have to specify it okay
and then i'm going to form a function f
of x oh and by the way how do
i if i say i'm thinking of a function f
and somebody says what's your function
i have to explain what does f give
for an arbitrary argument right and so
here here's what i'm going to say i'm
going to say that when you give me
x f is going to calculate the inner
product of a and
x and that just means f is going to
calculate a
weighted sum of the entries of x okay
and the weights in fact are the
coefficients in the vector a here so
that's how that's going to work
um so that's the inner product function
it's very natural
and it turns out it's linear so let's
see why
well here this we're going to form this
linear combination here
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to apply f and by definition to
apply f means takes the inner
just says take the inner product with a
so that's that's the inner product of a
and this vector and we're going to use
some properties of the inner product
um so for example you can if you have
the inner product of a vector with the
sum of two other vectors it's the same
as the inner product of the first one
with the first the vector with the first
one
and the plus the vector with the second
one so that's this second line here that
tells us that we can write it this way
over here um okay
and then we're gonna use another
property of the inner product and that
is that
scaling a vector which is an argument in
a linear in an inner product
is the same as scaling the inner product
and so what that means is that the alpha
and the beta can go outside notice
something interesting here
right inside here alpha x is scalar
vector
multiplication in the next line alpha
times that's a number so that's actually
in the next line
alpha is actually engaged only in number
number or scalar multiplication
okay and then we recognize uh inner
product of a
with x and inner product of a with y
those are nothing but f of x and f of y
so we get this and sure enough
this says that f of alpha x plus beta y
is alpha
f of x plus beta f of y and that holds
for any x and y
any alpha and beta right so that means
it's linear
so okay so that so so there are linear
functions
any inner product function is a linear
function now it turns out
in fact it's more in fact that's all the
linear functions there are so
another way to say it is this suppose i
tell you simply that a function is
linear you know absolutely nothing more
about it
then it turns out we can actually write
it as
the inner product of x with a vector a
uh
for an a and we're going to be very
specific about what a is
a i is simply f of e i and remember that
e i
is the ith unit vector and it looks like
this right
it's got you know well it didn't come
out well
drawing but the idea is uh it's
it should be a vector with all entries
zero
and one one in the i position and that's
it
okay so it says a i is you apply f to
that vector you get a number that's a
i okay and let's see why well
f of x is now here we're doing this kind
of very simply expansion
we're saying that x is equal to x1
that's its first component times e1
plus x2 times e2 plus x3 and so on
now that's expressing x as a linear
combination now
this thing you can apply the
superposition rule recursively
and you'll find that f of a linear of a
of a linear combination
is the linear combination of f applied
to each of the vectors and so that's
the equation down below and this thing
we see that is exactly the inner product
of
a and x where a
is give is the vector whose entries are
f e i
so we see that okay so um oh by the way
this is called the
the inner product representation of a
function i mean
of a linear function sorry it's a bit
silly but it says that any any linear
function has an inner product
representation
okay so so okay it's just a fancy name
for inner products
okay we're also going to encounter
something called affine functions uh now
a function that's uh
if it's linear plus a constant it's
called affine
oh let me point something out about a
linear function if f is linear
we know now that it has to have the form
in a it's an inner product looks like
that
and we can immediately calculate that f
of 0
is 0. actually we didn't even need that
form we knew we know that if it's
linear well this follows immediately
from linearity is that
a function has to map zero to zero oh
and just
heads up that zero is a vector
this zero is a number right that's the
number zero
that's the vector zero right so and we
don't distinguish them
after a while i'm going to stop pointing
these things out and it's going to be on
u
to keep track of you know what the
notation means and things like that
and especially to disambiguate the
overloadings right so
overloading is when you use the same
symbol to mean different things
depending on the context
so this is a perfect example after a
while you get used to it
i won't mention it anymore maybe every
every now and then i will just for fun
but the point is this is some is a very
important thing to get used to is you
can write stuff down
super easily looks good but you have to
actually just
always always make sure you understand
exactly what the notification means
okay so an affine function
is a linear function plus a constant
okay
and in this case if it's affine then f
of 0
is actually b and b is a number
and in fact some people call b the
offset right or the
that's a that's one of the names for
it's an offset in the affine function
um okay now it turns out an affine
function is also characterized
by a superposition type uh a
superposition type equation and let me
let me show you what that is um it's
this it says you form a linear
combination of
x and y that's alpha x plus beta y and i
apply f to it
and it says i get the same thing as this
now by the way if
f is if f is linear this
identity here holds for all x and y
all alpha and beta that's linear okay
maybe superposition
okay now if f is affined
this formula holds whenever
uh it holds but for a restricted set of
alpha and beta they have to add up to
one
alpha and beta right so um they they
could be
0.3 and 0.7 uh minus 0.3 and 1.3
something like that these are these are
pairs and if
for all such combinations you satisfy
superposition
then f is offline right so that's how
that works
okay now um oh and i should say
something um
sometimes when you have a linear
combination where the coefficients add
to one
some people refer to that as a mixture
uh it's a special kind of linear
combination but people call it a mixture
because you think of it as thirty
percent of this seventy percent of that
now
a mixture allows you to have negative
weights but that's okay as long as they
add up to one
okay um one thing to to uh one thing to
know about affine functions is that a
lot of people actually call them
uh call them linear and you know maybe
that comes from high school or something
and i'll explain that in a minute um but
i find functions generally are not
linear
so so here's a quick example in this one
n is one so x is a one vector
otherwise known as just a number so
here's here's x along this axis
and i can plot x that's this blue line
here now on the left
f is linear and the slope by the way
here is exactly a
so a in this case is a one vector
otherwise known as a number
and so a might be i don't know if this
were drawn to scale might be
i don't know let's say a third or
something like that one third point
three there that's what that's
that's what a is for this picture point
two i don't know um
point five sorry um okay so this is what
and notice that it you know goes through
zero and it's a straight line and in
fact the way we get the name
linear uh is because the graph
is a line it's a line so it kind of
makes sense right i mean or at least i
believe that to be the etymology of
of linear function but okay on the right
over here
we see a function that's offline it is
not linear it's for sure not linear
because a linear function goes through
zero
and g of zero is here and it is very
much in fact
this is b um if this if g of x
is a you know i'm going to write as an
inner product even though the inner
product of two numbers is silly
it's just the product but i'll write it
that way just to remind you
and so this is b here and then the slope
here
is you know minus one quarter or
something like that a is minus a quarter
so that's an affine function and i think
even in high school people
talk about i think i here's here's what
i remember maybe your notation was
different but i remember people saying
like
it was something like this as i recall
uh don't quote me on this
uh but and that was the equation of a
line something like that you know m
is the slope and b and you can see it's
just an affine function but i guess
they don't tell high school students
that's an affine function anyway it's
happening so
oh um so anyway you will not
you you will find lots of situations
where people refer to alpha functions
linear
that's cool but if you're around like
weird picky mathematicians if you don't
know them that well
you're probably better off referring to
affine functions correctly as affine
so but if you're with friends and
everybody knows all this then
you know you can call them linear if you
like